Howard yeah you probably should speak to
Ronnie um he appears to have lost his
voice doing something like oh boy real
oh is that what was going on cuz they
say good morning to him this morning and
he didn't answer me did you lose your
voice I didn't detect that kind of oh
what'd you do nothing you know what it
is you know what it is seriously and I
don't mean to bum you out it was a rough
weekend yeah knock you guys this way no
voice guys 70 years old and I said to me
sounds it did you go to bed early last
night
yeah meanwhile I was looking at the
video of Ronnie at that racetrack didn't
like you for that yeah it's the funniest
thing you got to watch it
why is it funny because it's cool with
Ronnie Ronnie is the only one at this
racetrack rest in a full racing out he's
got the job oh my god he's got on who's
like rinsing out specially fit my
monster him did Stephanie wear a special
racing outfit now the guy said yeah you
have a suit wear it so I brought it
Ronnie's walking around in that
superhero it's like it's like if I went
to see the Batman movie I dressed up as
Batman he's the only one like that I was
fine yesterday my voice was fine wasn't
it here's what's going on with him the
guy pushes hard yeah so what one time I
lose my voice big [ __ ] deal all right
hey if you're not upset about not upset
at all right suppose this becomes the
norm I bet you never get it back it'll
come back what he's trying to do is keep
up like a young person and keep up with
a young woman yeah he's [ __ ] like a
maniac he's up till 3:30 in the morning
drinking I don't know boys could last
until yesterday we didn't go out we know
nothing
and his body went out when I went to
sleep yeah
his body's exhausted yeah 70 [ __ ]
years old so what so what big [ __ ]
deal you're trying to [ __ ] like you a
teenager it's nothing wrong with that
dude all right well try to get your
voice back soon it's I find it annoying
I love it okay thanks for I can't take
it maybe I'll get him a wheelchair in a
blanket
oh well stop the forget it I'm too tired